la réalité budgétaire c'est 3000
milliards d'euros de dette c'est un
déficit budgétaire important c'est que
nous avons anciens avançant un budget
qui nous est proposé qui ne parlent que
de dépenses et qui ne diminue pas les
dépenses publiques en contre particulier
dans les dépenses qui sont légitimes
mais tous les contextes sont ainsi sa
course en déficit mais on pourrait se
dire c'est pas beaucoup quand il voit
tout ce qu'on dépense oui 5% de déficit
c'est beaucoup par rapport à d'autres
pays
c'est beaucoup dans la situation où les
taux d'intérêts eux augmentent où il y a
aujourd'hui la la nécessité et j'allais
dire de converger les uns vers les
autres dans le cas de l'union européenne
nous pouvons pas rester le pays parmi
les plus endettés je rappelle à 1000
milliards donc le edge est dans ce sera
non ce